الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان على ابواب
انتخابات مرتقبه في حال فوزه فيها قد
يتمدد حكمه المستمر منذ عشرين عاما لكن
هناك ملفات بمثابه حجر عثره خاصه اقتصاديا
ابرزها ارتفاع التضخم لمستوى هو الاعلى
منذ 25 عاما حيث بلغ اكثر من 85% خلال
اكتوبر الماضي حاول الرئيس التركي الدفع
باجراءات تحفيزيه غير مسبوقه للخروج من
الازمه تتضمن دعم الطاقه ومضاعفه الحد
الادنى للاجور وزياده المعاشات التقاعديه
ومنح فرص لتقاعد اكثر من مليوني شخص
الا ان الزلزال شكل له تحديا اخر المعارضه
وبعض الاتراك يحملون حكومته مسؤوليه حجم
الكارثه بين استجابه بطيئه وملفات فساد
ففي السنوات العشرين الماضيه منحت السلطات
تسعه قرارات عفوا كان اخرها في عام 2018
لمبان تعتبر غير قانونيه بينما يرغب
الكثيرون في معرفه اين ذهبت اكثر من 38
مليار دولار تحصلت عليها الحكومه عبر
ضريبه الزلزال التي بدات تطبيقها في اعقاب
زلزال عام
1999 لكن التقديرات تشير الى ان خسائر
تركيا سترتفع بعد الزلزال فتكلفه اعاده
الاعمار ستكون باهظه الثمن وثقيله على
الاقتصاد التركي قد تصل الى 100 مليار
دولار
المعارضه التركيه كانت تراهن بثقل كارثه
زلزال على حكومه اردوغان وتنبات بان تكون
القشه التي تكلفه خساره الانتخابات لكن
استطلاعات الراي تعكس حظوظ اردوغان وتشير
لفوزه بنسبه 49.8